اعلنت الشرطه البريطانيه انها تتعامل مع
احادث خطير ومستمر في مدينه نوتنهام وسط
انجلترا جاء ذلك تزامنا مع اغلاق عدد من
الشوارع ووضع خدمه الطوارئ في حاله
استنفار مع انتشار كثيف لافراد الشرطه كما
تمت مطالبه السكان بالبقاء بعيدا عن منطقه
الحادث مشاهدينا معنا هاتفيا مراسله
العربيه مستفزه اهلا بك مصطفى وماذا يحدث
في
حقيقه بحسب ما جاء في بيان لسوبر انه تم
اغلاق العديد من الشوارع في وسط مدينه
اثناء التحقيق في مسمته
بحادث كبير يتم التعامل معه من قبل عناصر
الشرطه وايضا شهدت العديد من مركبات خدمات
الطوارئ بالاضافه الى ان الشرطه ناشدت
الناس ومستخدمي المركبات بتجنب هذه
المناطق هذا الاغلاق لعدد من الطرق في في
اخبار ان تم اغلاق على الاقل سته شوارع في
وسط المدينه مما اثر على خدمات القطارات
في وسط المدينه وايضا حافلات النقل حتى
هذه اللحظه الشرطه لم تكشف عن طبيعه هذا
الحادث لكن بحسب تقارير اوليه بانه يتم
تقديم اسعافات اولياء لشخص على على على
جانب من هذه الطرق التي
تم بالطبع
يعني بحسب المشاهد التي تم نقلها حتى الان
العديد من عناصر الشرطه متواجدون في هذه
المناطق بالاضافه الى سيارات وحافلات
يعني الاسعاف بالاضافه الى الدفاع عناصر
الدفاع المدني بطبيعه الحال كل كل ما كل
ما اشاهدها حاليا وهو فقط خدمات الطوارئ
في في الشوارع لكن الكل يتساءل يعني سبب
هذا الاغلاق بهذا الحجم حتى في وسط
المدينه وفي ذروه يعني التنقل في في البلد
وبالطبع الكل يترقب ما هي طبيعه هذا
الحادث هل هو يتعلق مثلا يعني
بحدث يعني
عرضيه اما انه ربما هناك حادث يجب يعني
التعامل بشكل
حازم خاصه في في ظروف استثنائيه تشهدها
البلاد بالطبع الكل يعني يريد معرفه
المزيد لكن حتى هذه اللحظه الشرطه
تعل
ن عانت له دوافع تتعلق بجرائم او ارهاب
وما الى غير ذلك وبالتالي يعني نحن بحاجه
الى مزيد من
ربما سيتم تقديم بعض المعلومات في وقت
لاحق يعني بطبيعه يعني حاليا اشاهد يعني
مشاهد من وسط المدينه ليس هناك اي من
المشاه ليس هناك اي مشاهد للناس في وسط
هذه الماده فقط عناصر الشرطه متواجدون
وهناك
لاغلاق هذه الشوارع بالاضافه الى
[موسيقى]
يعني مختلف المركبات وخاصه تلك التي
تتعامل مع الحرائق لا ادري ان كان هناك
حريق ضخم في هذه في هذه المنطقه لكن
هناك مصطفى شح كبير في المعلومات لكن هل
من الطبيعي او المعتاد ان تتعامل شرطه
بريطانيه بهذا الشكل مع مثل هذه
الحوادث اعني هنا التكتم على طبيعه هذا
الحدث ومطالبه السكان في ذات الوقت توخي
الحذر من امر مجهول بالنسبه لهم في
المواطنين بالتاكيد
يعني
حدثت
في مدينه
نوتنغام لكن بالط
بع فرصه يعني ربما يزيد من التكهنات حول
طبيعه هذا الحدث وبالتالي لربما سنسمع بعض
اصيل حول هذا الحدث قريبا وخاصه وان كل
الانظار الان تتجه الى هذه المدينه
الواقعه في شمال انجلترا لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات